this Sunday a divided country president
took the oath of office and hundreds of
thousands of people gather president's
false claim that the media are
consciously you might assume that
America is outraged by Trump's
presidency but for millions of people
across the country like here in Jackson
Mississippi that's not the case or the
daughter I've been in regular contact
with Joni Horne throughout Trump's
journey to the White House she loved him
in The Apprentice boardroom what does
she make of him in the Oval Office we
hitched a ride on the school run a lot
of people are terrified by the prospect
of the next four years how do you feel
about that I'm excited I mean I'm very
excited I mean he give him a chance you
know all he is trying to do is make it
better
inauguration day the next day the
women's March even more people did you
understand why they were there no I mean
I'd you touched it tomorrow surely no
not at all I didn't know what was going
on you know but I mean Trump did get a
lot of fat women out there walking so
you know that's a good thing these are
the people who care about America well
then they shouldn't be so psychotic I
mean there's no red he's not he hasn't
done anything you know he hasn't come
out and said I'm gonna kill your
firstborn child you know I'm gonna
destroy the earth they have it object to
duty the travel ban for example whether
that's a good thing he should tell you
institutional well I'm having to predict
he's trying to make us safe he's trying
to make us safe and if you don't want to
be safe then pack your bags and go to
another country I love you
Joni says she's happy and confident that
she and her family will prosper under
trial yeah so let's put him some more so
we just ended up powering all their PR
executives Rick and Liza loser are
traditional conservatives who couldn't
bring themselves to vote Trump but now
he's presidents they support him
they've even sense growing confidence in
business since he was elected what I say
in Donald Trump it's the fact that he
has been in business his entire career
he knows how to run a business so he
understands what we're going through and
but they're finding the pace of it all
overwhelming we are sick and tired
we spent 18 months in an election that
was extremely contentious you know and
now in three weeks it feels like another
18 months and I think the American
people have just lost the ability to
give a damn and so I think there is a
very small segment that hang on every
single word that's going on in
Washington
but for the rest of America which I
would say is 90% they're all kind of
shrugging their shoulders going hey we
had an election elections have
consequences
he won let him do what he said he was
going to do he's pretty much been the
way was in his campaign he's Daniel
Murray light Trump first start and gave
him his vote here not without
reservations that haven't gone away
what's been a highlight for you so far
of trans presidency he's doing what he
said he'd do keeping promises yeah he
said I'm gonna do these things and
that's what he's doing and you gotta
admire that
now do I agree with everything and I
agree the pace all that probably not but
but you know what he's doing what he
said he doing it that's refreshing most
politicians don't and worst moment so
far
um I think just twittering and tweeting
and doing all the other things that you
just go out you know take a breath and
you know you got to be thick-skinned to
be in that position and I think I think
that'll come around with time
Trump's maverick presidency is gathering
pace the journey is taking America in a
new direction no one knows where it will
end
Amanda Walker Sky News Jackson
Mississippi